all eyes continue to be transfixed on
the johnny depp and amber heard 50
million defamation trial welcome
everyone to entertainment tonight can we
just be honest we can't look away oh no
no not at all the he said she said
testimony zeroing in on one big question
was amber a victim of domestic violence
this as some famous faces addressed the
court what is your understanding of why
mr depth
lost pirate sex it was related to the
accusations that amber has made from the
x's former agent christian carino who
was once engaged to lady gaga to
hollywood's go-to divorce attorney laura
wasser who johnny hired the court heard
plenty today we subpoenaed video
from the lobby and elevator areas
johnny
is definitely not here grainy body cam
footage was also shown from the night
cops received a domestic violence call
in 2016. miss heard had no visible
injuries several testified in johnny's
favor depp maintains he never abused
amber and claims she's making it up did
you
observe that amber heard and her friends
were attempting to concoct an abuse hoax
none that i can recall
but is johnny distracted this clip of
the actor doodling a portrait on a
post-it went viral on tick-tock and yep
julie bowen sees the similarities
between her and this forensic
psychologist who examined amber being
hot-headed is
really characteristic they might claim
abuse to essentially try to keep their
partner from leaving the therapist told
the court heard exhibited signs of two
different personality disorders
borderline personality disorder a lot of
the key features that you're going to
notice are instability
when it comes to histrionic a lot of the
key features are going to be drama
and shallowness do
always be the center of attention and
remember how amber seemed to be copying
johnny's courtroom fashion many thought
she was trolling him but the
psychologist explained it could be
another symptom in a lot of ways they
might mimic the way they dress people
with this disorder actually
take on the identity of the people
they're spending time with because it's
comforting